let's go next to paul garcia from mexico
welcome paul
hi david can you hear me i can hear you
fine
oh okay uh going going back to the
andrew yang uh third party proposal yeah
you remember it of course uh what would
you like to see what would impress you
from a third party
well i would like to see a third party
that's to the left of the democratic
party but not made up of people who are
cuckoo for cocoa puffs like the green
party that's what i would like to see i
would like to see an actual
socially democratic party that's to the
left of the democratic party
could could they be like um
if the third party got power you know in
the in the us yes i don't know the
senate or something in in the future
right could they
do like uh direct voting on on issues
like
you know because he talked about general
consensus is and and stuff like that
right yeah
andrea um
so could they
both pass like do you want this or that
and think about nationals well that's
not really a question about third
parties it's just a question of how our
political system works i mean are you
saying if you had members of this
imaginary third party in the senate is
that what you're saying
yeah could could they be could they do
that bigger reform or if they were in
the senate they would get a vote i mean
i think i might be misunderstanding your
question but wherever these third-party
candidates were elected they would be
able to vote and influence policy
whether it's the house or the senator if
you had a governor or whatever the case
may be i i apologize if i'm
misunderstanding the question
no i i think you're getting it right
just
i think it would be like a
constitutional change i guess
my question
yeah
the the constitutional change might be
required to get the third parties
elected the way things are going but i
have said i have clips about how third
parties could could make inroads but
that's its own complicated reality as
well
yeah oh yeah thank you paul where what
part of mexico are you in
uh chihuahua
last time i was i was here i told you it
was kind of getting chilly yeah you were
like uh how cold is it and i was like uh
i don't know minus five or something you
said like well that's
barely getting cold but have you ever
been in a dry cold air
dry cold air i
i guess i don't know the sensation is
completely different here in
the cold i know you you in uh near new
york right yeah
so you you get really
cold
winters yes
but i've been in the us in uh humid
regions and minus 17
celsius yes feels like
minus 10 here i swear well i believe it
i believe it what's the elevation where
you are do you know
uh it's around 2 000 meters 2000 meters
oh wow that's and you're are you
completely acclimated to it
it feels fine no headaches nothing
uh i i'm from a small town i live now in
a city here is like one
one thousand four hundred my town is two
two hundred two thousand two hundred so
it's
it's
it feels the change you feel it when you
go back and forth i bet i bet all right
paul well thank you for the call
thank you too all right a beautiful
phone call from our friendly neighbors
to the south
in mexico where i hope to return very
very soon folks that does it for calls
today
my apologies i throw myself at the mercy
of those who i was unable to get to
but i can assure you if i have anything
to say about it
and i believe i do
we will take calls again
and i will speak to you next week but
we'll just gonna take a quick break and
then the show continues